AS WE GO TO OUR NEXT
GAME, YES WE CANNABIS.
YES WE CANNABIS.
PRESIDENT OBAMA SAT DOWN WITH
VICE NEWS TO SEND A STRONG
MESSAGE TO YOUNG AMERICANS.
NATURALLY, THE TOPIC OF
MARIJUANA CAME UP.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> YOUNG PEOPLE, I UNDERSTAND,
UH, THIS IS IMPORTANT TO YOU,
BUT YOU SHOULD BE THINKING ABOUT
CLIMATE CHANGE, THE ECONOMY,
JOBS, WAR AND PEACE.
MAYBE WAY AT THE BOTTOM YOU
SHOULD BE THINKING ABOUT, UH,
MARIJUANA.
>> HARDWICK: OKAY, BARACK
O-BUZZKILL.
SO IN HONOR OF POTUS' THOUGHTS
ON MARIJUANA, COMEDIANS, I WANT
YOU TO COME UP WITH AS MANY
PRESIDENTIAL STRAINS OF WEED AS
YOU POSSIBLY CAN.
UH, I'M GONNA PUT 60 SECONDS ON
THE CLOCK.
AND BEGIN.
(BELL DINGS)
YES, ERINN HAYES.
>> JAMES K. TOKE.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
ROB HUEBEL.
>> VAPE-RAHAM LINCOLN.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
DAVID WAIN.
>> FRANKLIN D. WHOA-SEVELT.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
ERINN.
>> PUFF, PUFF, TAFT.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
ERINN HAYES.
>> MARTIN VAN BONGLOAD.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
DAVID WAIN.
>> LYNDON BONG JOHNSON.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
ERINN HAYES.
>> MR. GORBACHEV, TEAR OPEN
THOSE CHIPS.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
ROB.
>> RUTHERFORD B. HAZY.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
ERINN HAYES.
>> MOUNT KUSHMORE.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.